gina carano a star of disney's
star wars tv show the mandalorian has
been cancelled
she has been cancelled apparently for
something that she said about the jews
which sound it sounds really bad you
know and bigoted and everything we're
going to get into what she actually
said i don't think she said anything
wrong whatsoever but but even more
broadly
if disney executives don't like what
gina carano has to say about the jews
just imagine their shock when they
google walt disney i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from django
mike
who says i'm a brown brown-skinned
brown-haired brown-eyed native american
who is a white supremacist according to
the woke left because i don't want to
toe the line with their lunatic ideas
you are i know i mean i i know that
you're you're sort of saying this
tongue-in-cheek
but they believe this i mean they say
this about uh candace owens
or ben carson or thomas soule
or uh or clarence thomas or the you know
sort of pr
especially black but you know other
racial minorities too
who are conservative they will say you
are a white supremacist
you are you're maybe not aware of it but
you're laboring under a false
consciousness and that's why we need to
raise awareness
raise consciousness and make you woke
right it's all talking about the same
thing
and that way you'll realize that you're
oppressed you think you're happy and
content you'll have to realize you're
oppressed
and then you will stop supporting white
supremacy
that's the thing you've you've got to
come on up you know if you want to make
sure that you're in the best sort of
health and wellness uh vim and vigor
you got to check out hymns for hymns.com
is all about men's wellness need help
with ed
hair loss or have a cold interested in
mental health or covet 19 home tests
hymns is here for you through hymns you
can get the prescription medication that
treats
ed real science real solutions to ed
this could cost
hundreds of bucks if you had to go
through a doctor or a pharmacy
not so with hymns hymns makes it simple
and affordable no embarrassing
conversations no expensive appointments
just answer a few questions online about
your medical history and a provider will
confidentially review
if you're approved your medication is
shipped directly to your door in
discreet packaging
and shipping is free no more searching
online for answers to questions about ed
or sexual wellness
i know for men sometimes we don't want
to talk about these things
go to your hymns account ask a medical
professional you can trust try hymns
today
by starting out with a free online visit
go to forhims.com
michael for your free visit that is for
hims.com michael
f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com slash michael
prescription products are subject to
medical provider approval and require an
online consultation with a medical
provider who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information remember that is for
hims.com
michael a simple solution to problems
that are pretty common
go check out hims i think i was a little
unfair to walt disney
you know walt disney there was this kind
of rumor that he hated the jews or
something he was kind of a bigot
there's actually really no evidence of
this uh but
i figure it's a funny enough hit same
cannot be said at baby yoda though i
can't believe they haven't canceled that
guy yet
you get a couple drinks and baby yoda
you you set him off talking about the
jews and the mexicans and the italian oh
my gosh
it's like it's like little green david
duke or something
but gina carano didn't say anything
wrong uh
disney put out a statement based on gina
carrano's old social media posts
you say her social media posts
denigrating people based on their
cultural and religious identities
are abhorrent and unacceptable
oh gosh abhorrent nonexistent okay what
did she say so i pulled up the post this
is
the worst post they could find this this
is the height of her bigotry
on social media gina carano wrote
jews were beaten in the streets not by
nazi soldiers but by their neighbors
even by children because history is
edited most people don't realize
that to get to the point where nazi
soldiers could easily round up thousands
of jews the government first made their
own neighbors hate them simply for being
jews
how is that any different from hating
someone for their political views
like she's saying the nazi regime had
this hatred of jews
ethnically and religiously and so it's
not like they just came in one day and
everyone was being really nice to the
jews and then the nazis said well no
we're going to be
awful to them and round them up and you
know commit all these atrocities
no they fomented a culture in which jews
were otherized
castigated whatever term you want to use
and gina carano is saying
this can be done politically as well
this can be done to people based on
their political views
just as it can be based on their
ethnicity or based on their religion
duh of course that's true there's
nothing it's not denigrating jews at all
she's denigrating nazis but that seems
perfectly fine
is the issue here for disney that gina
carano was making a
nazi comparison is disney saying you
know it's it's wrong
to invoke any sort of nazi imagery ever
when making a political point
uh fair enough but if you were to if you
were to hold that view then
most people would fall silent because
the only two historical events
most people especially leftists know
anything about is world war ii and the
fall of the roman empire right that's
all those are the only sort of events
anyone ever invokes
joe biden just did this joe biden just
compared donald trump to goebbels
like a few months ago we're not
the the left the entire left has been
calling
donald trump literally hitler and
calling 75 million americans nazis for
years but it's
it's wrong when carano she's not even
com exactly comparing the democrats to
nazis she's just saying
that this kind of culture in which
conservatives are being ostracized and
censored
and deplored that has historical
parallels
is that is that the issue here
really the reason they're doing this
because i actually thought gina carano
had already been fired
this story came up months and months ago
and it's it's not because she said
anything about the jews or because she
said anything about the nazis or because
she said anything about anybody
it's because she is a conservative and
she supports trump and she's made fun of
woke culture and so the fix was always
in they were always going to try to get
her
now they're using this ridiculous excuse
it's kind of like what they did to megyn
kelly
which is you had people on network news
who
wore blackface right you had uh
what's her joy behar darkened her skin
for a costume you had people on nbc
where megyn kelly
was working who would wear blackface
in sketches totally fine but then megan
kelly one day was discussing the topic
of blackface she said you know
if you were to darken your skin to be
part of a costume to portray an
individual not a race broadly but an
individual
is that okay and they fired her for it
they call it her blackface controversy
is it as if raising the mere topic of
blackface was so offensive
and yet for the other hosts to actually
wear it not offensive at all it's it's
because
there's no principle here it's just that
nbc didn't like megan kelly so they were
going to kick her out
people are calling this cancel culture
i wish we could retire that phrase
because i don't think it's helpful it's
obviously describing a real phenomenon
we're seeing it's where
conservatives or anyone who's not a
radical leftist
gets ostracized or fired or censored uh
for refusing to adhere to left-wing
orthodoxy so it's a real thing that's
happening
but a cancel culture doesn't describe it
there are plenty of people who should be
cancelled i'll give you an example just
at disney
james gunn made all those jokes about
how he wanted to have sex with children
if anybody is going to be canceled james
gunn should be the one to be canceled
not gina carano
i'll give you a further example though
because james gunn might say well i was
kidding it was in poor taste but i'm a
comedian and so
you know you got to give me a pass mark
hamill luke skywalker
is accused of trying to coerce his son's
girlfriend who his son had knocked up
into killing the baby
so mark hamill allegedly
pressured his son's girlfriend to
kill his own grandson and there are
apparently texts and messages and all
this sort of
stuff if that is true
mark hamill should be cancelled he
should be not just fired from star wars
not just fired from disney he should be
removed from polite society he should be
ostracized
he should be shunned he should be
canceled he should not be invited to
participate in things
it's a very very bad thing
he certainly should not be invited to
participate in things until he repents
and says he's sorry
and acknowledges how awful that is
because nobody seriously opposes
this broad definition of cancelled
culture nobody seriously believes
that there ought to be no consequences
whatsoever
for things that people say and do nobody
believes if gina carano had walked onto
the set one day
and said zig heil heil hitler and had an
uh swastika on her clothing nobody
believes she should keep her
job what people are when they when
people oppose cancel culture what
they're saying is
that it not that there should not be
standards by which people
rise and fall in their careers but
rather
that the standards that people are being
judged by are ridiculous
because in the olden days you would be
judged by traditional standards if you
violate the traditional moral order
or traditional social mores you would
face consequences
but now it's completely upended
standards it's left-wing standards
and that's the real problem but let's
let's not overstate our case let's not
say we're free speech
purists what does that mean there's
never been such a thing as free speech
purism there have always been
categories of speech that are not
permitted
in society and sort of behaviors that
are not permitted
what we are saying we're actually saying
something a little harder i think
conservatives think it's really
simple it's easy it's inoffensive to
just say
we support all speech we support all
actions we don't want any standards it's
really easy this is why we've lost on
political correctness
we need to say something that requires
more courage we need to say some things
are right
some things are wrong you should be
permitted to say and do some things
and you should face consequences for
saying and doing other things
we have to be willing to do that that
kind of a regime of speech and behavior
is going to exist it has in every
society and always will
it's just right now we've completely
seated that ground to the left here's
something else we should cancel gender
theory
we should cancel it we shouldn't permit
it this radical gender theory that says
that men can be women and women can be
men
you can't have a society that holds both
views at the same time
because they're contradictory views
either men are men and women are women
and
one cannot become the other or there's
no such thing as men and women and men
can be men and women can be
become men can become women and women
can become men see how confusing this is
and there's really no no such thing as
an immutable
natural category of sex but you can't
hold both at the same time because
they're contradictory
so we have to cancel one we have to
exclude one we have to censor one
and the one we're going to cancel should
be gender theory this is what's
happening right now in utah
utah house of representatives advanced a
bill that would ban
quote biological boys from competing on
female sports teams
there's no such thing as a biological
boy
as distinct from some other kind of boy
i may have been i mentioned this the
other day but i may have been a little
confusing in my language
there's just boys they're biological
boys they're spiritual boys
they're boys in every way and i actually
think we air when we
when we qualify these terms well he's a
biological boy but he's
therefore he might be some other kind of
girl i don't why are we qualifying boys
or boys girls and girls that's it
don't qualify if you're if you say well
i'm a biological boy but i think i'm a
girl well then
but you're a boy you're not a girl
you're you're a confused boy
utah trying to ban gender theory north
dakota just passed a similar bill
the the lesson here is that real freedom
requires certain limits it excludes
certain things it can't include
everything
chesterton had a great line he said
there's a thought that
that undermines thought and that's the
only thought that ought to be
undermined right there there's uh
if we don't have any limits in our
society then we don't really have a
society
you see this most clearly with borders
right the physical limits of our society
if we don't have borders to our society
then there's no country right because
people can just come and go as they wish
there's no delineation of jurisdiction
there's nothing holding the people
together there is no people it's just
nothing you need you need limits in all
aspects of this
finite world and we need to acknowledge
that
and i know it's we're in a sort of
underdog effort right now
to try to prove that to people but if
you want to listen to a true underdog
story check out the true underdog
podcast really fabulous raised in a
trailer park with no clear path to
success
kicked out of high school multiple times
and faced with becoming a father in his
teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog
after hearing the words no or you can't
too many times he unleashed the power
within to start three successful
companies
with his most recent venture power home
solar skyrocketing on a path to becoming
a billion dollar enterprise join us as
waller a four-time entrepreneur of the
year winner
shares motivational tips and inspiring
stories and business building lessons
from the ground up he shares his life
experience
and that of his high profile guests to
help others better themselves
as waller will tell you there is no
elevator to success that climb happens
just one step at a time let every true
underdog podcast be that step that
elevates you
scared money won't make money learn
about failure learn about
entrepreneurship
learn about never quitting or making
excuses it's real it's raw
it's motivational head on over i really
enjoy
you know getting sort of motivated by my
podcasts that i listen to
check out true underdog podcast at
trueunderdog.com or
wherever you get your podcasts go give
it a listen
something else that we should cancel
these days gavin newsom
evan newsom is the failed governor of
california some of us call him nussolini
he should be canceled he should lose his
career we should hear from him no more
he should go be a private citizen and
enjoy fancy dinners at the french
laundry and live his life
the effort to recall gavin newsom is
actually picking up steam
you know this has been going on for for
years now they've been trying to get to
one and a half million
signatures to recall newsome and then
force a new election and you'll have a
lot of different people running they've
done this in california before that's
how we got schwarzenegger
we have 1.4 million signatures right now
you need to get by march 17th you need
to get 1.5 million so you'd say okay
we're very close it's easy we're going
to get 100 000 signatures
but it's actually not that simple
because what's going to happen then
is democratic operatives are going to
come in and start taking out signatures
and disqualifying them and saying that
guy no longer lives here that's not that
guy's address right
this happens in every campaign so you
actually need to have many more
signatures
than the 1.5 million threshold you
probably need like 1.8
maybe even 2 million signatures to
really make this work
good news the rnc is investing a quarter
million dollars
into the california recall campaign
right now so the republican national
committee is finally getting involved
this to me is a very good sign thus far
the rnc has not gotten involved because
these are long shot campaigns the rnc
has finite resources
so they don't want to blow it on a
campaign that's not going to work the
injection even of just a quarter million
here
is a signal that there's a chance this
recall effort is going to work they're
going to
need to put some money in here just
especially as the democrats start
putting more money to tamp down
the recall effort republicans are going
to need to get a lot more signatures
maybe half a million more you know even
even within the next month or so uh but
that's a good sign we should cancel
newsome somehow newsom is not even the
worst governor in the country right now
the worst governor in the country a man
we should certainly cancel andrew cuomo
you know andrew cuomo has gotten credit
for being the greatest governor on covid
even though his state leads
in or is at least very near to the top
in total death count death rate
just an absolute failure in the handling
of coronavirus and this guy had the
unmitigated goal
to write a book about leadership lessons
from covid it probably has the same
content as my
first magnum opus reasons to vote for
democrats totally blank book
so we've been saying for months and
months i spoke to my friend who's a new
york state assemblyman kevin burn the
other day
we've been saying that cuomo is directly
responsible in his policies for
a lot of extra deaths particularly among
senior citizens particularly in new
york's nursing homes
the media won't cover this sort of thing
but now it turns out we're right andrew
cuomo's top
aide her name is
secretary to the governor melissa derosa
she just admitted and apologized in a
phone call
to democratic lawmakers for the cover-up
in new york nursing home deaths during
the covet epidemic
a cover-up i used that word very
specifically this
woman says that the cuomo administration
quote
froze out of the fear that the
nursing home deaths quote the numbers
would be against us
by federal prosecutors and therefore
they wanted to hide the numbers from the
feds so there wasn't an investigation
thousands and thousands and thousands of
new york senior citizens died
needlessly because of the cuomo
administration's policies
they knew this at the time when they
realized it they hid the numbers
not just from you and me and the public
but from federal investigators and
prosecutors
because they knew how bad this looked
she says
we apologize we do apologize i do
understand the position that you were
put in
i know that it is not fair
now i'm hoping listening to this that
she's apologizing to the families of
these dead senior citizens right
it was not fair we put you in this
terrible position i'm so sorry
no that's not who she's apologizing to
she goes on
it was not our intention to put you in
that political position
with the republicans the woman is not
apologizing
the cuomo administration is not
apologizing to the families of these
dead senior citizens she's not
apologizing to the senior citizens
themselves
she's apologizing to democrats because
they're reckless policies that killed
thousands of seniors
and the cover-up that followed put
democrats in a bad political position
that's the kind of administration we're
talking about this man andrew cuomo
the worst governor in the country a
truly corrupt politician
i've had the uh privilege or displeasure
of
of meeting andrew cuomo a couple times
because i actually we're from
right around the same town in new york
and uh i
run into him in other places a real
bulldog type of a guy a
pure political animal he's been in it
since his dad was governor
it was clear to anybody with two eyes
what was going on during covid
but the mainstream media refused to
report on it take a listen to their
as andrew cuomo's policies were killing
all these seniors and as he was covering
it up from the feds
this is how the media covered him david
we're standing by for governor cuomo's
press conference his daily briefing
how would you contrast cuomo and
president trump's handling of the crisis
truth versus mendacity governor cuomo
out there day after day after day
everything trump isn't
honest direct brave real leadership of
the kind the president of the united
states
should have provided governor cuomo is
clearly living in a totally different
reality
the actual one than the president of the
united states governor cuomo has become
a national leader
for a lot of people andrew cuomo has
become the leader of the democratic
party he is conveying incredible
strength
you spoke to national guard troops today
in a stirring
speech that if i wasn't listening
carefully i thought you would sending
soldiers off to war
this has been a remarkable show of
leadership by governor cuomo in recent
days
he's providing hope but not false hope
governor cuomo i think is
is one of the heroes on the front lines
with all of this
adulation that you're getting for doing
your job are you thinking about running
for president
are you you should be you're doing such
a good job andrew cuomo you're doing
such a wonderful job
says his brother chris cuomo how corrupt
is this whole edifice
all the while they were pushing this
propaganda
this dude cuomo was through his policies
killing senior citizens
and through his other policies covering
it up
remember that next time you trust the
media the media this frankly that
might not even be the most embarrassing
set of clips i've seen from the media
recently
the most embarrassing one might go to
the the eulogy
for the founder of hustler larry flint i
didn't actually even realize larry larry
flint
had died larry flint dies and
this guy is one of the most famous
pornographers in the country other than
hugh hefner probably the most famous one
and to show you how far our
speech regime or our understanding of
the moral order has
fallen and how much it has shifted in
recent decades
listen to the way that cbs covers the
death of this pornographer
flint fought several high-profile legal
battles and became a target for
feminists and the religious right
flint died of heart failure in los
angeles he was 78 years old love him or
hate him he was a controversial figure
uh but he really did change the way
people thought about the first amendment
that's absolutely true he was also i
mean it's interesting he was he opposed
the death penalty he
favored same-sex marriage he spoke out
against the u.s invasion of iraq
politically he was very progressive
he was not what you might think that
larry exactly
yeah some and some reader of hustler
left a copy in a construction site when
i was 10 near my friend's house
what'd you do with it and it changed my
life forever
here you are on pbs how about that
this is very embarrassing for these
people
on on many levels it's funny line you
know i found this
this porn mag and it changed my life
forever when i was 10 years old
i think that's true you know i think
that actually is true
part of the reason right now that on the
right this porn debate has come up this
question should be regulate porn or ban
porn
you'll notice it's come up not from gen
x or the boomers or even millennials
it's really come up from gen
z why because gen z is the first
generation that grew up
with the internet all the time basically
in a world saturated by
not just a little nudie magazine but by
high-speed internet porn
from the age of 10 or whenever i think
on average it's people are about 11
years old when they first discover porn
in these younger generations and it can
really ruin your life
you know it can really make your life a
lot harder i think
people make fun of these zoomers when
they say we need to regulate porn
they say oh yeah you probably look at
porn yeah they probably do
because something like what is it 92 or
something of men
look at certainly have looked at porn i
think in terms of have seen
naked ladies on the internet it's like
92 percent of men have done it and eight
percent of men are lying is what what
people say about the
the statistics yes they realize it's a
real problem and larry flint
is in no small part responsible for that
i couldn't get over it when that
reporter said
you know though believe it or not larry
flint was politically very progressive
gee you don't say oh i thought he was a
conservative
republican i thought he was like edmund
burke but oh he's progressive the
pornographer wow
shocking yeah larry flint when
republican politicians would oppose
the ubiquity of porn he would go in and
try to gin up sex scandals for them
in the 1990s he endorsed mark sanford in
2013
for uh south carolina's first
congressional district because he said
quote his open embrace of his mistress
in the name of love
breaking his sacred marriage vows was an
act of bravery that has drawn my support
that guy should be canceled that kind of
that sort of culture
should be canceled that view of the
first amendment which is completely at
odds with the
with the understanding of our founding
fathers and the history most of the
history of our country
that should be cancelled it has to be
you can't have both views
you can't have the view of the founding
fathers of the first amendment and the
modern view
at the same time one view says we need
to prioritize liberty not licentiousness
licentiousness will destroy liberty
then modern view says licentiousness is
liberty can't have them both you got to
pick one
we should pick the founding fathers we
can all pray for larry flint's soul
but when we think about his legacy we
should not
celebrate it in the way that that cbs is
doing
you know one thing we can celebrate is
getting
a great deal on auto parts you can do
that at rockauto.com rockauto.com is a
family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low they're the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers and
the catalog is so easy that even i can
navigate it you know
look i'm not gonna not gonna pretend to
be somebody i'm not
i'm not the handiest guy in the world
okay when i go into the brick and mortar
auto parts store and they start asking
me questions about whether i need the
doohickey for the gizmo on my gt7 hondas
i don't know
if i have a i have a honda i don't know
you tell me what i need
then they go in the back they charge you
twice as much and they probably order it
on rockauto.com anyway
skip all that nonsense rockauto.com
makes
their selections so easy so simple even
i can do it go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck
simple enough if i can do it you can do
it then write knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
in there how did you hear about us box
that way they will know that we
sent you go check out rock auto family
business so simple
to navigate even i can do it go check
out rock auto
so the journalists have
completely humiliated themselves not
just in the last
few weeks obviously over many many years
but but especially in the way they've
covered cuomo
especially in the way they've they're
eulogizing
pornographers it's that is embarrassing
stuff meanwhile
real journalists real investigative
reporters doing real work
who are exposing crooked leftists are
getting cancelled themselves
james o'keefe james o'keefe from project
veritas he's having his
main project veritas account being
kicked off of twitter why is he being
kicked off of twitter
allegedly for sharing private
information the real reason is because
he's investigating big tech
so one of his investigators goes up
finds a facebook's vp
guy rosen and starts talking to him
outside of his home
twitter now says this is private
information because they showed part of
the guy's house in the shot obviously he
was outside there
and therefore uh you know he's got to be
kicked off of twitter
james o'keefe responds and says that's a
ridiculous double standard
project veritas talked to rosen outside
his residence we asked him for comment
he did not reply there he is when you
talk about
freezing comments containing hate speech
what do you mean by that
the vp of integrity at facebook
showing how much integrity he has
there's nothing in this tweet that
violates private information
by the way it's the paragon of
television reporting to speak with
residents outside their homes when it
comes to matters of public importance
cnn also confronted an alleged russian
operative inside an apartment building
the telegraph does this all the time
many reporters
speak with people outside on the street
it's just what reporters do so we're
actually not going to delete this tweet
yet because i think it would be
unconscionable for me to
have a different standard than the
mainstream press
fair enough james o'keefe is making a
very narrow point here
which is this is a typical practice of
journalists
and they're holding me to one standard
and they're not holding everyone else to
another
broadly speaking i think it's very wrong
to go to the houses even if prominent
people are public figures
where their wife and children sleep you
know i
i'm very fortunate to live in a state
with uh
a broad understanding of the second
amendment and if anybody shows up to my
house to try to
do any of us harm that would be
unfortunate for that person
so i in a way i'm i'm actually quite
sympathetic to the
facebook vp's point of view here but
we're talking about a speech regime
we're talking about how big tech is
going to handle this and
the way they're going to handle it is
not with a standard i'd actually be
perfectly fine saying
can't show up to people's houses anymore
sorry can't do it
okay fine you want to apply that across
the board i think maybe that actually is
a little bit more civilized than what
we're
looking at now but that's not the
standard the standard is
you can do whatever you want to the
conservatives you can have elected
democrats saying go show up to
conservatives houses
and scream in their windows and scare
them half to death
you have actual prominent democrats
doing that meanwhile
if a conservative reporter shows up to a
liberal guy's house and starts asking
questions
can't do that speaking of investigative
journalism this is a story
we don't have too much to talk about
here but i do want to at least bring it
up
uh interesting piece in national review
by andy mccarthy
this was based on reporting by revolver
news asking a simple question what
happened to officer
siknik officer siknik is the capital
police officer who was killed
following the riot on january 6th
we've been told by the new york times
and others he was killed by this
pro-trump mob we've been told
that he was killed because someone
smacked him over the head with a fire
extinguisher but what andy mccarthy does
here and what the what the revolver news
piece does that the national review
piece is based on
is asking uh is as asked this question
why is the timeline changing we still
don't have a cause of death for officer
sicknick
this event happened more than a month
ago the story has changed now we're told
he didn't die
at the capitol he wasn't taken to the
hospital from the capitol as we were
initially told he actually went back to
his office and then something happened
and that the story doesn't really add up
he had texted uh an associate of his
later on after the capital and said oh
i'm fine you know
i it doesn't say anything about a head
wound there doesn't seem to be any
evidence of a head wound now so
the story is very strange obviously the
death broadly
terribly sad event but we need to know
exactly what happened because this is
being used as
the the chief piece of evidence against
donald trump
in this impeachment trial that the chief
chief
mode of ginning up this emotion
uh during the impeachment trial we don't
know what actually
happened and no journalists are really
looking into it other than these guys a
revolver and now andy mccarthy
at national review the central feature
of this impeachment trial
as you'll have noticed if you've been
paying any attention to it which i don't
recommend that you do
is not argumentation they're not making
the argument
that you know trump really committed
this impeachable offense that they're
referring to as incitement
they're not really they're not
establishing any serious
legal standard for incitement they're
just trying to gin up emotion and
playing lots of videos that really have
not a lot to do with the case so senator
cruz was asked about this
and he said yeah the impeachment trial i
was just with senator cruz in dc we were
talking about it as well
he said you know this this trial it's uh
it's a lot of smoke but there's
it's a lot of hot air but there's no
nothing really there
well i think we'll see that the trial
continue for the rest of the week
um it it is reminiscent of of
shakespeare that it is full of
sound and fury and yet signifying
nothing
right sounds about right andrea mitchell
from nbc heard senator cruz describe the
impeachment trial this way
and she took to twitter to say quote
senator cruz says the impeachment trial
is like shakespeare
full of sound and fury signifying
nothing no
that's faulkner i
i saw that tweet and i thought is this
real
is this a real tweet and it's fine i saw
senator cruz maybe an hour after she
sent this and he comes to me and says
you're going to get a real kick out of
this did you see what andrea mitchell
just said i did i couldn't i didn't know
if i was missing something
and i actually see how she might have
gotten a little confused because
faulkner has a novel called the sound
and the fury which is but the
the title is based on shakespeare the
sound and fury signifying nothing this
is one of the most famous lines
of shakespeare in in his entire body of
work
i'm sure you've heard it before the
whole the whole little bit is
tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow
creeps in this petty pace from day to
day
to the last syllable of recorded time
and all our yesterdays have
lighted fools the way to dusty death out
out
brief candle life is but a walking
shadow a poor player that struts and
frets his hour upon the stage
and then is heard no more it is a tale
told by an idiot
full of sound and fury signifying
nothing
tail told by an idiot what i loved about
andrea mitchell's tweet and to her
defense she later apologized and she
left the tweet up kind of
took her took her lashings on social
media what i love about it is this
combination
of ignorance right she doesn't know
where the quote is from
and arrogance to me that perfectly
describes our liberal elite
ignorant uneducated
they have good credentials i think
andrea mitchell went she went to a fancy
school i actually majored in literature
or something
a lot of good that did her but also
extraordinarily arrogant
they they really think that they're so
much smarter than all the people who
came in the past
and all the republicans and all the half
of these deplorable
americans
you know you're going to hear a lot of
calls for unity and healing
you already are but
there is a way we can unify and heal and
the left understands it and
the right does not actually bruce
springsteen sum this up
one of the one of the great minds of the
left relatively probably is
bruce springsteen a far left winger uh
he
he had an ad during the super bowl where
he talked about how we got to get back
to the middle this was an ad for jeep
cars and trucks but
it was really a political ad take a
listen there's a chapel in kansas
standing on the exact center of the
lower 48.
it never closes all are more than
welcome
to come meet here in the middle
it's no secret the middle has been a
hard place to get to lately
between red and blue between servant
and citizen between our freedom
and our fear now fear has never been the
best of who we
are and as for freedom it's not the
property of just the fortunate few
it belongs to us all
whoever you are wherever you're from
it's what connects us and we need that
connection
we need the middle we need the middle
now it's it's ironic because bruce
springsteen is one of the most radical
left-wing guys
in public life you know in the
entertainment industry
uh and he's talking about how we need to
be in the middle it's also ironic
because
it's an ad for jeep and bruce
springsteen just in the last few days
got
busted on a dewey he was drunk driving
so that's kind of funny too
but i actually want to get to the point
he's talking about he's saying it's all
about the middle we got to me in the
middle
how is the middle defined the middle has
moved a lot
in the last 60 years in this country
it's moved very far to the left why
because the middle is defined by
boundaries the middle is defined by
the leftmost limit and the rightmost
limit
and beyond those limits you get canceled
right beyond those limits
you are not allowed to say those things
those are not socially acceptable
some people call the overton window the
window of acceptable dialogue
the middle is defined by where the ends
are where the limits are
therefore we need to define those ends
we need to get past this kind of vague
talk about cancel culture
and actually talk about the limits talk
about those
ends what the left has done very
successfully is they've pushed the right
side of it
wait wait in their direction so now if
you're just a mainstream regular old
conservative you're gina carano and you
say i like donald trump
and you use a kind of basic political
metaphor that everybody uses
you get canceled you're not allowed to
say that meanwhile on the left you can
say i hate my country you can bail out
rioters you can do it
you can kind of do whatever you want and
you're totally fine so if we want to
reclaim the middle we've got to reclaim
the boundaries and move them back
in a saner direction drew is going to be
talking about
gina carano getting canceled so tune in
for that on the andrew clavin show
he's also going to be talking about
china and christian politics you know
daily wire membership it's the only way
you should be viewing
daily wire content right now using promo
code knowles
you'll get 10 off any membership plan
you choose
you will get oh gosh i don't know i
don't even have time to throw the daily
wire content we keep adding stuff it
seems like every single day
so you will get all that wonderful new
content
you will also get 10 off when use promo
code no stop depriving yourself come
join in on the fun we'll be right back
with the mailbag
welcome back my absolute favorite time
of the week
the mailbag first question from skyler
dear mr knowles on your show you said
that you were strongly opposed to the
free market mentality that many
conservatives continue to maintain in
light of the big tech oligarchy
regarding this what is the remedy you
propose outside of the free market
and if your remedy is found in
government intervention how do you
justify it looking to the government to
solve our problems
i hope that this piques your interest
i'm a big fan of your show and the daily
wire result thank you very much
i want to clarify because i don't think
this is my position
at all i'm not strongly opposed to the
free market i love the free market
i consider myself a strong defender of
free markets
in their proper place
the free market is a wonderful
instrument for human flourishing
but the free market is not an end in and
of itself
it's not a political end in and of
itself nor is it
even a practical concept there's no such
thing as a purely free market
the the market is defined by its
boundaries which are defined through
politics
and you want you want to have a robust
market setup but there's no such thing
as a market without boundaries the more
even
you know just think of a regular
physical marketplace the physical
marketplace has
uh boundaries to it it has different
shops in it it's got different rules of
how exchange is done it has currency
it has all of these kinds of features
that that we get not from
our brilliant reason and abstraction
exclusively
we get it also from our tradition we get
it also from practice we get it also
from our ritual
we get it also from how it's existed in
america before so
specifically to your question on big
tech
you're right i i think that the
heretofore conservative line of uh you
don't like
big technology companies controlling the
flow of information build your own
google
build your own twitter i think that's
preposterous these are not
private companies in any real sense of
that word they work with the government
they work with the ruling regime
they are monopolistic in many ways
they've
they've grown in large part through
fraud by defrauding customers and what
they are really getting
what kind of freedom they'll have on the
platform and by exp
exploiting legal loopholes notably as
we've often talked about
not just on this show but on the right
through section 230 of the
communications decency act
so yeah i don't think we should have any
sentimentality for
for these big tech companies that what
they are doing is controlling the flow
of information
in what is the public square now which
is the internet and in a republic in a
self-governing republic
that communication that that ability to
persuade people that is politics right
that is how politics is conducted so we
can't allow them to have that kind of
power
what am i proposing you're saying are
you going to turn to the government for
help you can't turn to the government
government can't help you this
presumes a what i think is
a an unfortunate view of politics that
has cropped up over the last 20 or 30
years or so
on the right that that says basically
there's no legitimate role for
government whatsoever
to do anything in society if we really
believe that we are
anarchists do you think that
conservatives
if they're really being true to their
principles are anarchists
no the the only anarchists we see in
public life right now are the ones in
portland with antifa
burning down buildings do you think
they're conservative do you think
they're right-wing
no there is a role
for the state i'm a great defender of
the state just like i'm a great defender
of free markets i'm gonna go on the
other side now say i'm a great defender
of the state
in its proper place the state is good
law and order is good
you can't have freedom without law and
order
without a state to protect the rules
you know to police certain people to
protect private property among other
things
you don't want the state to get out of
its place
when you make an idol out of the state
you become a statist
statism is wrong when you make an idol
out of the free market
you become i don't know worshiper of
mammon or something i don't know
you you go very wrong though chesterton
had this great line he said that
you know heresy generally speaking he's
talking about religion here obviously
heresy is not the promotion of vice over
virtue
so much as it is the promotion of one
virtue to the exclusion of the other
virtues out of place
you know he was he's talking about his
friend george bernard shaw who uh was a
sort of radical atheist socialist pretty
good playwright actually but you know
radical left winger but he was friends
with chesterton he said the problem with
bernard shaw is not that he doesn't have
a great big heart
he's got a very great big heart but it's
in the wrong place
so we don't we want things to be in
their proper place we want
markets we want a state we want a
respect for the individual we want a
respect for family and in
these civil institutions we want them
all ordered toward
the good which is what which is what
society aims at
the constitution is clear about this
right to promote the general welfare
to secure the blessings of liberty not
even liberty is an end in and of itself
liberty is an instrument to secure
the blessings of liberty which is human
flourishing
ultimately ordered toward the good i
hope that clears it up from timothy hey
michael thank you for your insights and
wisdom thank you for the compliment
i have a question about george orwell i
recently looked up orwell on wikipedia
i was shocked to see them proudly
proclaim that he was a democratic
socialist
how can that be true it seems to me that
1984 is not just a rebuttal of
totalitarianism but also of socialism
orwell describes in the book how
capitalism created so much surplus in
the world
that the governments had to come in and
control the supply so that the people
were kept in a state of constant misery
how could a socialist write this book
thank you
yeah it's a good question this comes up
a lot orwell was a democratic socialist
and he said actually in other writings
he said everything i've written
is in defense of democratic socialism
with an important caveat
as i understand it and uh i hate to
presume to say that he didn't understand
it very well but
what you have to understand the
historical context of the times
end of these terms you just use the term
capitalism capitalism is a word
basically popularized by coral marx
right
it's a term that is the reason we use it
today is basically because of communists
and marxism presupposes capitalism
capitalism is actually a part of marxism
it's a stage
in historical development after which we
can then you know overthrow our shackles
there will be a big class revolution and
there will be no state in this kind of
utopian world
that of course never happens in reality
so when orwell is writing he's writing
against
stalin stalin that is to say the reality
of the soviet union
but he's still laboring as so many
intellectuals labored at that time
probably most intellectuals labored at
that time under the idea that
socialism or even i suppose communism
could be redeemable it's just they got
the wrong one you know
you see this with the trotskyists and
the trotskyites
they're called both terms which is
people who were disillusioned with how
stalin was running the soviet union
but they couldn't they couldn't admit
that that
stalin was a natural conclusion of their
ideology
so they they had to say no it just went
wrong you know true socialism
true communism has never been tried if
trotsky had
held power you know this kind of rival
of stalin if trotsky had held power then
we would have this utopia on earth and
it's just not true
uh you know trotsky because he didn't
really amass ultimately this political
power
he's made this kind of martyr of the
true good communism but you know if
trotsky had power would have been the
same exact thing
stalin just managed to do it and
one could one could go on at great
length about what actually happened in
the soviet union
but uh uh suffice it to say
orwell was writing against
communism and socialism in practice and
uh
he was not able to give up his his views
of uh
what socialism could be which which was
true of virtually all the smart people
at the time and even many smart people
today
even though they're so so misguided on
it from owen dear michael
i was just confirmed into the catholic
church and my saint name was thomas
after saint thomas aquinas uh what was
your saint name
and what is your advice for me as i move
on to the next phase of my faith thanks
and god bless wow that's so wonderful
i uh my confirmation name is also thomas
i don't know if it was thomas the
apostle
or thomas aquinas i picked it
when i was 13 when i was a precocious
and
ignorant little agnostic veering toward
atheism
and i chose that name one because thomas
was a doubter and also because thomas
aquinas
was very intelligent so i think i chose
thomas the apostle i consider
thomas apostle to be my confirmation
saint but i don't know i guess it could
have been thomas aquinas too
hope i get both of those guys to uh you
know pray for me
um i am right now reading boethius
or rereading boethius i haven't read
them since college uh
on who's consolation of philosophy and
on who's writing
uh thomas aquinas uh or from who's
writing thomas aquinas draws great
inspiration
uh so and i'm also watching all these
series from the to mystic institute so
i'm really trying to delve a little bit
more into uh
to thomas aquinas so that's great i
would encourage you to check out
boethius and the mystic institute
and most importantly to just make sure
your prayer life is uh
and your ulti the ultimate prayer you
know going to the holy mass and
receiving the eucharist and receiving
the sacraments
um to make sure that you are doing that
regularly nightly rosary is
very very important sort of thing and uh
welcome home that's great
from bernard hello michael wonder if
this is bernard shaw wouldn't that be
weird from beyond the grave
he's looking up at us right now from
from the afterlife
i hope that you and your new baby are
doing well greetings from a fellow trad
catholic oh that's great
good to hear from you so my question has
to do with something you said
that was not the focal point of anything
that you were saying but it always
irritates me when people say it why did
you say that america was founded with
plymouth rock in 1620
not jamestown in 1608. i get that you
have a personal connection to the
mayflower
and i'm asking you this question
realizing that it is commonly taught
i just do not understand why people
place so much importance on plymouth
rock
that they literally act like jamestown
never existed i mean isn't that kind of
insulting to virginians like washington
jefferson madison
henry et cetera to write out the first
english settlement in the states
great great question i'm so glad you
asked this because it's true
uh jamestown happened before the
mayflower jamestown was 1608 right
uh the slave ship arriving the 1619
project happened before the mayflower it
was 1619 mayflower 1620.
we just celebrated the 400th anniversary
of the mayflower
the reason i trace america's founding to
the mayflower
and the reason that so many people in
american history have traced it to the
mayflower is that the mayflower provides
a philosophical and a theological basis
for the country
in a way that jamestown did not
obviously jamestown contributes to the
founding of america christopher columbus
large greatly contributes to the
founding of america
i guess 1619 in a way contributes to the
founding of america i guess a lot of
these things did
1776 obviously is the founding of the
country and yet we tend to
trace the founding of our country
earlier
right it's the founding of the united
states but we tend to trace the founding
of our country earlier
i choose 1620 because i think it
represents
the in economic ways
in cultural and social ways in religious
ways a sort of coherent vision for the
founding of the country
the 1619 project did not seek to rewrite
american history that's what they ended
up
kind of doing because they had they lied
in many ways about the american
revolution
but what that woman nicole hannah jones
said she wants to reframe american
history
history has to have frames you know
you're kind of defined by the limits
right
and i think we ought to frame uh
american history largely
on the mayflower on 1620. i think that
frames the country
in a way that is true to to its
history the conservative history and
even the kind of puritanical
neo-puritanical progressives
i think american history makes a lot
more sense
when you look at it through the lens of
the mayflower than through other lenses
all right that's our show i'm michael
nolan's michael knowles show
see you monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show